valiant hearts is a unique puzzle
adventure that follows the emotional
journey of four characters and their
canine companion through the horrors of
the trenches across the Western Front
Ubisoft is also proud to announce their
partnership with the documentary
apocalypse world war 1 coming soon on
the American heroes channel some of
their incredible colorized photos and
archival videos have been included
within the game providing a new way for
players to interact with history and
adventure in this beautiful stylized
universe literally bringing art and the
past to life
to my dearest friends for the evil noise
of artillery tanks and planets
I remember our Avengers friendship and
my closest friend Emil and your twilight
years we came to fight but to mend your
daughter's tears
lucky Freddie
you were always fearless and within
taste I hope you have found peace with
your letters that were never sent
Donna the bravest of warriors across the
western front saving the mountain of
wounded without firing a shot and Karl
the only length of light your way home
through the fields of war for
treacherous nights to be with your
family once more although I cannot write
these words and the time has come to
part their stories will always remain as
will your valiant hearts